am wahltag geben zwar die wählerinnen
ihre stimme ab aber einen sieger muss es
deswegen noch lange nicht geben denn
nach abgabe der stimmen in den
wahllokalen müssen noch die
briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt werden
und die dürfen in manchen bundesstaaten
noch bis zum wahltag eingeworfen werden
danach kommen die wahlleute ins spiel
jeder bundesstaat hat eine festgelegte
anzahl davon wyoming 3 das
bevölkerungsreiche kalifornien 55 der
künftige präsident braucht mindestens
270 war leute auf seiner seite
durch das system der wahlleute gewinnt
nicht immer der oder diejenige mit den
meisten wählerstimmen
so wurde hillary clinton 2016 nicht
präsidentin
obwohl sie landesweit fast drei
millionen mehr menschen gewählt hatten
aber donald trump hatte mehr wahlleute
und zog so ins weiße haus ein
in fast allen staaten gilt das prinzip
winner takes all die partei deren
kandidaten von den wählern mehrheit
nicht gewählt wurde darf alle wahlleute
des jeweiligen bundesstaates bestimmen
selbst wenn das ergebnis noch so knapp
war heißt wer zb in florida knapp
gewinnt dessen partei bestimmt dort alle
29 war leute die dann im elektro college
für ihren kandidaten stimmen nur selten
weicht eine wahl person vom auftrag ab
die entscheidung der wahlleute fällt
dieses mal am 14 dezember